خيبه امل لصناع فيلم باربي ياسمين عبد
العزيز تعلق على نبوءه انفصالها عن احمد
العوضي مفاجات حفل كاسيه 90 في موسم
الرياض واطلاله تخطف الانظار لهيفاء وهبي
اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع كانت ليله جوائز الجولدن جلوب
بنسخته الحاديه ليلله سعيده لصناع فيلم
السيره الذاتيه اوبنهايمر الذي فاز بعدد
من الجوائز الكبرى بما فيها جائزه افضل
فيلم درامي وافضل مخرج كريستوفر نولان
وافضل ممثل درامي لكيلي ميرفي بطل الفيلم
وافضل موسيقى اصليه بينما شعر صناع فيلم
باربي الذي حقق ارقاما قياسيه من شباك
التذاكر حول العالم العام الماضي بنوع من
خيبه الامل فبعد ترشيحه لتسعه جوائز لم يف
صناع الفيلم سوى بجائزتين فقط بما في ذلك
الجائزه الافتتاحيه للانجاز السينمائي
نفت بسمه بوسيل ما اثير عن عودتها للفنان
المصري تامر حسني وذلك في قصه نشرتها عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستغرام واوضحت ان
الصوره التي نشرها تامر احتفالا بالعام
الجديد كانت لاسعاد اطفالهم لانه لا
يستطيع قضاء راس السنه معهم لا اكثر بحسب
قولها واعتذرت لمتابعيها عن سوء
الفهم وعلى نحو طريف علقت الفنانه المصريه
ياسمين عبد العزيز على تنبؤ عبد اللطيف
بانفصال ياسمين عن زوجها الفنان احمد
العوضي خلال العام الحالي هي مرحله
الانفصال عن زوجها الممثل احمد العوضي
وبشكل
مفاجئ بينما يحتفل العوضي بانطلاقه عروض
فيلم الاسكندراني لمخرج خالد يوسف عن قصه
للكاتب المصري الراحل اسامه انور
عكاشه
ايالي بقت من غيرك ماليها الو
ومن مصر الى السعوديه والنسخه الثانيه من
حفل كاسي 90 التي نظمها موسم الرياض
بمشاركه نخبه من اشهر نجوم الغناء في مصر
والعالم العربي خلال فتره التسعينيات احيا
الحفل مصطفى امر ايهاب توفيق مدحت صالح
هشام عباس ومصطفى
[موسيقى]
كامل وكانت مفاجاه النسخه الثانيه من حفل
كاسيه 90 مشاركه فريق اكوا والمغنيه
السويديه جيني والمغني الالماني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هاي وفي موسم الرياض فاجا خالد ابن النجمه
المصريه ليلى علوي والدته بالاحتفال بعيد
ميلادها على خشبه المسرح بعد انتهاء احدى
عروض مسرحيه الصندوق الاحمر من بطولتها
بمشاركه الفنانه ميمي جمال وبيومي فؤاد
ورنا رئيس وممثلون اخرون وتستعد ليلى عروي
لانطلاقه عروض فيلمها الجديد ماسوم خلال
شهر يناير الجاري بنايل نغني عشان كل واحد
يروح
بيته اخيرا
وباطلالة
n